outfit and they're gonna get wreck at
speedrunners good
everybody's laughing easy when you have
a Mitchie beau wait what
Oh Emma laughs go laughs all right
before we begin this is me this is so
this is my town and that's Alfie let's
go home
no why are you do the opposite of an
alphabet
no one is still sliding Oh Alfie I
wanted to get one time huh no oh no no
no come on I'm just pretty much over am
i serious ah
so bad are we playing this map every
time I see good at this man
oh I was watching my expression bum and
Mayas stuff it is very bad might say
wait up for me
imma listen I see it yes so nice man can
you stop ditching your body's really
striking no finish as I spun I thought I
missed it yeah dammit no ha ha don't hit
that yeah no no no Widow
I am still in the screen hit the pivot
to 3/4 away no double use the Rockets
are really bad you're better oh hello no
I can't take it
gig oh no no no yeah oh no you're really
bad at these aren't you trying to
distract him okay you're a girl I think
you know I'm a man leave a unicorn
are you oh yeah oh [ __ ] that's so bad oh
yeah
what do you [ __ ] all grapple what are
you doing
no oh you don't have you got you don't
grab oh oh what that what is he doing
come on don't Apple me it's really bad
it's bad for you yes this green is so
sure
god no I can't look I can't watch this
no wait am I going yeah wait one ding Oh
it wasn't get away oh no watch them big
hole back go back
what's up I'll let you go
you've got rocky I think cause it makes
it it oh dear
don't use the rug it's a terrible I'm
sorry two dishes you guys thank you so
much okay let's change another man cuz
you guys it's another ye just check back
why am i outside why we're gonna say one
again everyone go left
is it really the same one no yeah okay
well you guys is practice
no you didn't do that oh [ __ ]
everyone is really trying hard trying so
hard oh it was the grapple don't do
speedrun oh jeez that's pretty good
no no what are you gonna grapple now
[ __ ] pulses no boxes Malcolm box me
stop it
no that's so fair don't use it no wait
wait wait uploads on max buttons
oh here's go grapple me don't get me
don't get me no these we're losing at
trials I don't even care no anything
Oh No just starts right away you want
boxes no what I got ya what we done
whatever gun oh yeah yes yes yes oh no I
got out yeah that one taken Oh big power
let's see the change my everyone's click
on that my second which one sunrise I'm
on that one where am I
everyone go left imagine your thought
was just the way to the end but so much
a reverse actually yeah
Jenny how do you even do that
mozzie amigo grapple in scenarios like
should tell me I'm feeling stupid spice
no yes yeah we're used to it girl
guffaws yeah yeah you want some BAM like
pong huh you want some boxes yeah
welcome on these ah oh jeez
oh really yeah I'm on the upper floor
awesome
what are you doing here he's my buddy
get on the spikes my ten games yes oh
really again okay we special what's this
one supposed to go
I told Jay oh you guys are literally
right message Rockets he likes them oh
yeah come on guys wait up
no it's not fun if you don't know that
choice words men [ __ ] well I'm gonna
wait grab folks no don't you dare
grapple me oh honey time the only time I
got damn boxes yeah you like boxes my
cheese
alphy wait up I'll see what are you
doing cuz to turn to watch it she's got
good legs hey I got a good leg soon
what are you doing with that so you like
crackling if you go example how would
you like oh I didn't give up it's all
about you know if I'm nice I like a hold
it huh
you should be one of those haunted house
girls oh I don't know I know is we got
good this way but like my father's bones
oh how did you do it Oh a box there
though you like rockets
how many Rockets do you like oh I'm
coming for you I'm coming fresh I'm
Kevin Frank do you like rockets she's
all yes yes yes yes I'll just wait for
you to grapple
now where's my grandpa Jesus you have to
like go back and then get speeding them
on geez
never mind oh you can get a no wait for
you come out
I'm very rapidly mess running speed ever
very beautiful oh you got smooth
discrete oh well I got my one
yeah eyebrows that's it for part 1 if
you enjoyed leave a like and let me know
and I'll upload more it's like at least
two more parts so let me know and hit
the sky recover today and I'll see you
abreast tomorrow the rest day awesome oh
you're welcome